i remember as a kid when i was a
bricklayer with my at the time
girlfriend i took her to the mecca of
all men's movies point break
now i'm in east london
fast forward to where i live now i'd
drive down the same streets where that
movie was actually made and go to the
same taco bar where that movie was shot
but at that time the movie went through
and there's a scene where they grab
johnny utah and they're gonna make him
raid a bank and it's patrick swayze
who's beau de cipher bodhi and bodhi
turns around to johnny utah in the back
of the truck because they said because
he says he's scared and he says
hesitation a fear causes hesitation
and hesitation will cause your worst
fears
to come true
now i remember that being said in the in
the movie house i can even tell you what
movie house it was
i never remembered the rest of the movie
i literally had to go back a couple of
days later to watch the rest of the
movie because i was so in awe of that
it's not the fear it's the hesitation
and i remember when i used to do
kickboxing and you get a punch in the
head it's not like hollywood you don't
go flying through the bloody window you
know and so you you always realize that
the fear isn't usually as large as what
you've given it credit for and then
there's the other side of it that says
hang on yes i'm scared
but what could possibly go wrong i'll
tell you what could go wrong i could not
try
and remain here
and joe polish actually said to me years
ago coined it our best
he said the definition of hell
is to meet the man or woman that you
could have been
now you only could have been that person
if you try i'll go around the corner
i'll get it wrong i'll go off into the
gravel hopefully i won't go flat side
sometimes it happens you know you you're
boxing someone someone gets a a a smack
through you go ah my guard needs work
this is all education
and so when you get back on it you go
okay i lost it at that corner oh i got
an uppercut here i've got to keep my
elbow in here that's the education
so for me
it's not the fear in trying
it's the fear of not
now here's my little backup thing
that'll make you pee yourself
i was at a vip uh but
thankfully because of my my branding and
stuff like that everyone knows i'm
heavily in a motorcycle so i get some
pretty
cool little things that i get involved
in within different motorcycle companies
i had a vip um race day the other day at
a track called chuckwalla in palm
springs the guy sat next to me at the
barbecue the night before
kiana reeves yeah i saw that clip on
your instagram of him riding his bike
yeah so i actually told him about it and
it was just hysterical that you know
years i went from being a bricklayer in
london
years later i'm actually sat next to the
guy that was in the movie that actually
caused me to water my mindset funny
little turn of events that's hilarious
and um have you have you ridden his bike
the company
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah how is it
it's uh it's a it's startling for a
start um
because i've also got a bunch of harleys
um and you look at it and you go oh it's
a harley it ain't uh it's a real light
talky twisty it's an incredible machine
now if you're gonna go on a race track
i'm happy erasing my ducatis than the
arch um and in fact that you know the
arches can go up to over a hundred
thousand dollars so i'm definitely happy
at riding my ducatis but um it's it's
not
it shouldn't be confused with the harley
davidson it's it's way much more of a
complicated technical bike than that
is it a four valve head on the arch or
is it it's an s yeah it's an sns v2
okay
um actually let's stay on bikes for a
bit because i got a whole bunch of notes
here it's you know since we're on it so
i packed in riding bikes around 30. i'm
48 now right and i've moved to supercars
um
i still like bikes so like i have this
itch that i want to scratch if you know
what i'm saying it never really went
away i kind of started riding bikes when
i was 18.
what now the last bike i had was a zx7
or a ninja uh 99 i think it was one of
the carburetor ones was the year loved
it to bits did everything i could ever
ask of it um the thing i notice about a
lot of bikes today you know when i look
at them is they're missing fairings
everything seems to either go in the way
of an ugly japanese bike or a ducati you
know with a fairing or it doesn't have a
fairing i like the wind protection when
i'm on the highway what's your
recommendation i mean is there a ducati
that you like i know that you're a big
duck guy
so i got seven so um i would probably
say yes um my oldest one's a 1985 melee
and my newest one is a v4r
um superbike um so
you know i i go through different things
i would say that before you answered
that question the first thing you need
to know or the first thing you need to
ask yourself is what is the experience
you're trying to generate
okay if on the station of speed
you can go for an older unfair end bike
and you'll feel as though you go faster
like you say about supercars all right
so if you're in a ferrari and i work for
ferrari and you go around the racetrack
and you're doing 170 mile an hour on a
ferrari and it's cool it's really really
good
but then you go around a corner in a
shifter car
at 30 mile an hour i've done that too
and you're [ __ ] your bits okay
the reason is because you don't have the
roll cage you don't have the protection
you don't have a roof um you don't have
the the the pleasure of all of that kind
of cocoon
you're now fully immersed that's one of
the things about motorcycles especially
with racetracks being out in the country
you'll literally go around a corner
and there'll be uh like a i don't know
some daisies in the field which you'll
suddenly be able to smell
because you've just got the helmet on
you'll walk through this scent of like
fresh cut corn or something
now you don't get that experience so if
you want the sensation of speed
go for something older with no fairing
if you want to go around a track fast
then get the fair in and you'll still
get a sensation because hey it's still
only a piece of plastic but you'll be
able to go faster on it there's a lot of
bikes that are naked now because quite
simply my v4r
the speedo clicks off at 180.
it doesn't register above that because
above that
you shouldn't be looking at the freaking
speedo so literally it just stops
um and if you look at race bikes like
mine it has a tachometer it doesn't have
a speedo engaged when you've got it
relevant
it's totally irrelevant so
but i've i've been on i've been on my
bike and i've done like 108 170 and it's
it's brilliant and then i've been on
naked what they call nakeds and street
fighters and those kind of things doing
50 mile an hour slower
and i'm immersed in more experience i've
got more wind on my chest it's like
going down the road looking out your
front window
at 80 mile an hour
and then rolling all the windows down
and looking at the grass next to you
it's ground rush
yeah i'm gonna have to write them both
then hey guys i really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you